I guess my job is to say welcome welcome
everyone I'm delighted to be here to
talk to you about this work we've been
doing at Yale for about 20 years on
emotional intelligence and as you can
see here my name is Mark Bracken I'm the
new director of the Yale Center for
emotional intelligence there's a pretty
rich history to this work Yale as many
of you may know our president who is
being inaugurated today Peter was the
originator of the theory of emotional
intelligence and he and my doctoral
adviser Jack Mayer back in 1990 wrote
the seminal article on emotional
intelligence that nobody read I was
lucky that I did read it but you know
how most academic articles go if you're
in the real world you don't get access
to this information
so the idea went pretty much unknown for
about about five years and then there
was a popular book written on the topic
by Daniel Goleman that many of you may
know how many of you are familiar with
that book on emotional intelligence how
many of them familiar with my book on
emotional intelligence yeah look around
the room now you know why I have low
self-esteem
yeah anyway
the mo yes the theme is that emotions
matter now you know more about that but
more seriously back in 1985 when that
book was written people started hearing
a lot about emotional intelligence and
then Peter and Jack and some other
researchers like myself started revising
the theory of emotional intelligence
developing measurement tools for it and
then studying it to show that it made a
difference so my job today really is to
share with you some of the research
we've done and also talk with you about
the programs that we developed that we
are now disseminating throughout the
world so with that note I wanted to
share with you what the vision of our
Center is the we've just converted
recently from what we called the health
emotion and behavior laboratory which
was a mouthful where we studied emotions
and health behavior but now we've
relaunched just this week officially as
the Yale Center for emotional
intelligence and the idea behind our
Center is to use the power of emotional
intelligence to create a more healthy
effective and compassionate society so
we're interested as you can see in
mental and physical health how emotions
help or hinder that life outcome being
effective in the workplace and certainly
making it the world a place where people
get along and can get ahead and along
with our vision we have a mission which
coincides essentially just adding the
ideas that we conduct rigorous research
and develop innovative educational
programming so our goal over the next
hundred years is to continuously do
rigorous research but also create
innovative educational approaches so
that we can teach people of all ages the
skills that we believe they need to
succeed so it's my job I think you've
been here it's this is a pretty amazing
weekend for all of us and how many of
you have been asked how are you feeling
like one person so I guess my job is to
ask you how you're feeling so I'd like
you to take a moment and think about
this is a wonderful weekend it's a
beautiful day we've got great people
here in the audience bring together the
past the present and the future of Yale
the first dimension on our mood meter is
called pleasantness it's what's going on
for you here in your mind's eye
it's your internal psychological state
and basically we can rate ourselves from
minus five to plus five plus five right
now today is the most amazing day of
your life there's nothing more than
you'd rather be doing than sitting
listening to some guy talk about
feelings minus five
you know you're like I think I'm
supposed to go to another workshop right
now not sure please give yourself a
number from minus 5 to plus 5 and now
I'm going to ask you to take your
attention away from here and bring it
here to your body
what is your energy like right now are
you low energy you feeling like you need
a triple cappuccino or are you full of
energy and feel activated minus five
would mean that you're about to fall
asleep plus five would mean that you'd
love to just jump out of your seat and
take over my presentation and of course
we're going to cross these two
dimensions and create our mood meter has
four colors yellow red blue and green
how many of you are in the yellow right
now you're feeling pleasant with a lot
of energy raise your hands okay
how about here in the green today
feeling pleasant but lower in energy for
some reason mostly people are sitting
the back
sort of reminds me of my teaching days
right if you're low-energy how many of
you are somewhere the red or blue today
something's not going right a little bit
red high-energy and unpleasant okay
we're going to keep our eye on you for
the day blue would be Low Energy
unpleasant so most of you are in pretty
good shape today yellow and green
just for curiosity is that the reality
of your everyday life for some of you
yes for some you're like no I'm never
yellow agree I'd like you now for a
moment to think about the word and
whatever language is your mother tongue
that best describes how you're feeling
at this moment take three seconds to
find that word and then we'll go dancing
freeze quick raise of hands how many of
you had some trouble finding the best
word put your hands up really really
high really high look around the room
please so over 50% of the room had
challenged it was challenge finding the
best word any hypotheses about why that
might be the case yes it's hard to sum
them up okay other thoughts yeah
think about it high-energy with a lot of
pleasantness jazzed happy elated
ecstatic so here we go we're going to
build your vocabulary now you've already
learned something write that in your
evaluation other hypotheses yes back
there sure so you might be having mixed
emotions like when you lose your luggage
when you're traveling right you're like
annoyed at the airline you're fearful
that you're going to have to go without
your clothes etc one more oh now you're
challenging me
so this possible is a possibility maybe
we just don't have access to our
emotional life because why I'm putting
it back on you now yeah it's it's
possible or perhaps maybe we've just
never been formally taught to go deep
into our emotional lives just for
curiosity how many of you drink wine
well okay how many of you like are
really into wine yes so sir like what
kind of wine do you like Italian wines
and what about the Italian wines do you
like the range what does that mean
exactly the fruits anything else
smoothness any particular notes or
flavors or dryness okay
so you can see you know if you like
something a lot you pay more attention
to it and you'll develop a sophisticated
vocabulary about it
my hope is after today perhaps you'll
develop a bit more of a sophisticated
understanding of your inner lives now
perhaps if I had asked you the reason
why you're feeling the way you are you
would have had a little more clarity so
take a moment now and think about you
chose a quadrant yellow green blue or
red I'm going to ask you to ask yourself
the question why
what's your reason that you put yourself
in that quadrant who can share who is in
the yellow raise your hand again okay
I'm going to use the front audience sir
why you in the yellow just because you
feel that way you feel happy full of
energy but is there a reason had a good
trip and everything is fine the weather
is nice you know so there's nothing to
do with my presentation you just
randomly showed up today okay
all right how about for you ma'am you
ever happy I'm motivated the inspiration
the progress
great well that's a nice thing to do so
there are underlying reasons why we feel
the way we do labeling is important how
about expressing emotions how many of
you believe that you are skilled at
masking your true feelings raise your
hand how many of you believe that even
though you're skilled most people read
through the mask okay so that's a little
bit of a conundrum there right we'll
talk about that a little later finally
I'm going to ask you to think about your
strategy so I'll be here for about an
hour talking about this work on
emotional intelligence and maybe you'll
go on a rollercoaster ride of emotions
maybe you'll go feel inspire then maybe
you get a little bored hopefully not
maybe you'll get irritated with
something I say you'll disagree my
question for you is what is your
strategy for sort of my goal for you is
somewhere between yellow and green I
don't want you to be too excited and
jumping out of your seats nor do I want
you to thinking sort of being the deep
green maybe like sitting you know on the
dock by the bay drinking a glass of wine
I'd like it to be sort of moderately
energetic and moderately pleasant so my
question to all of you is what your
strategy yes look at the positive things
in your life very good other thoughts
how about for this presentation remember
to breathe that's a good thing any other
strategies yes ma'am in the red pay
attention
that's an interesting I want to just go
to that for one second how many of you
have ever told your child to pay
attention yeah how many of you even done
it like this pay attention yeah
how many of you believe and how many of
your children like immediately just pay
attention yeah yeah so one thing I'm
going to challenge with you challenge
you today to think about is when you we
say things like how many of you have
said something like I need you to calm
down anyone yeah and how many of you
have shown in your own research that
really works well it tends not to work
very well pay attention I need you to
focus focus the question is what are we
actually doing to focus what are the
strategies were the underlying mental
processes that we're teaching children
and adults to focus to calm down to pay
attention what I've done for you so far
is really taking you through the
components of emotional intelligence I
asked you to plot yourself I asked you
to think how you feeling then I asked
you to think about the word and the
reason for your feeling state I ask you
to consider how are you expressing this
what is the how are you showing it to
the world around you how many of you
believe that where you are on the mood
meter is correlated with how you're
expressing yourself right now
rigea and if you're in the yellow please
okay so just to give you a little bit of
feedback some of you yellow high-energy
Pleasant you know I'm not totally clear
we go yellow is yellow here right and
then I'm asked you now at the end to
think about the strategy so my hope for
you during this weekend is that you're
going to be experiencing lots of
pleasant emotions joy contentment
excitement maybe even go to feelings of
ecstasy so what is this thing emotional
about emotional intelligence the
historical view of emotional
intelligence doesn't look so great does
it this is what ancient philosopher
stoic philosophers even psychologists
educators said
emotion passion and reason are
antithetical rule your feelings lest
your feelings will rule you so the idea
of an emotional intelligence millennia
ago or even just a hundred years ago
probably would not have occurred as a
matter of fact even more recently I was
taking your car service back from the
airport and the driver asked me he said
you know what do you do for work and I
said I studies this thing called
emotional intelligence
he said emotional intelligence that's an
oxymoron and that is the way most people
think about emotional intelligence how
can you be intelligent about your
emotional life when your emotions are
these idiosyncratic impulses that drive
you to different sides maybe the dark
side what we now know is a much
different story is that emotions matter
and they matter a great deal for
multiple aspects of our daily lives from
our attention memory and learning has
anyone here ever experienced anxiety how
many of you are being treated for
another yeah we know when we're feeling
anxious that it's hard to concentrate I
mean by definition you know our brains
are either ruminating or obsessing on
something think about for example a
child who's being bullied in school what
it's like for that child worrying about
going from Class A to Class B worrying
about going from school to home when
your brain is focused on dealing with
very strong unpleasant emotions
how can it be available for learning
think about it now that's a negative
example but the same thing goes with
positive examples when you're so focused
on your upcoming vacation you just can't
wait to go away that weekend very hard
to focus unless of course you have
effective strategies decision-making and
judgment just for curiosity how many of
you have ever made a bad decision
how many of you made a bad decision in
the last week so we're making decisions
every day of our lives every minute
pretty much and what our research shows
is that emotions are behind a lot of our
decision-making for example we now study
educators the lives of educators and
most recently we publish a study looking
at how teachers emotional states affect
their evaluation of their students so
how many of you I'm going to this is a
trick question now believe that grades
are objective nobody raised their hand
of course if I hadn't primed you you
might have changed your mind so we did a
study where we show that if we put
teachers in the yellow versus the blue
just by having them think about a good
versus a bad day that after that few
minutes of writing when we gave them an
essay a middle school students essay to
grade there were one to two full grade
differences between the teachers braids
who were in those different mood states
so what's interesting about that is not
necessarily I knew that was going to
happen because that's what I study
negative moods are going to shift you to
be more narrow positive those are going
to make you more expansive but for me
the most important piece was this after
the study was over we asked teachers do
you believe that your emotion state
influenced the way you evaluated your
student what percentage of the educator
said of course zero you're so
pessimistic again most 90% said there's
no way that my emotions would have
changed the way I thought about this
essay but yet when we shows in the bar
graphs there was a full grade difference
so what's interesting about that is what
what's interesting is that emotions are
affecting our judgments and decision
making but we're not conscious about it
we're not aware of it more soon
relationship quality how many of you
when you're at work or even in your own
family love to be around the
read this gruntal disregulated family
member anyone like you see that the
person I work is always irritated and
kind of nasty and you say that's who I
want to go for coffee with today most of
us don't want to be around people that
display a lot of negative effect nor do
we want to be around people who mistreat
us constantly lots in the relationship
quality area finally physical and mental
health when you think about what
emotional intelligence is the ability to
recognize and understand and regulate
our emotions how can we be healthy
physically or and mentally without
having effective strategies and
self-awareness so those decades of
research led Peter salivate and Jack
Mayer to come up with this idea of
emotional intelligence as a matter of
fact the history of this work is kind of
fun they were both doing independent
research projects that were along the
same lines and they became close friends
and Peter and Jack were painting Peters
house when he was an assistant professor
here living in Fair Haven and all of a
sudden they were having this
conversation they're talking about their
research and each one with the story is
nobody knows who really said it first
my guess is that they don't want to tell
anybody about it and all of a sudden
this idea says well what if there were
this thing called emotional intelligence
and then the AHA happened and the idea
was that there are two things one
individual differences that some people
are just going to be gifted in terms of
their emotional life they're going to
read people like that they're going to
have effective strategies to manage
their emotions other people will not be
so skilled in this area and the other
piece of it was that it could be seen as
a mental ability that there would be a
way to measure it and a way to sort of
study it to show that it made a
difference in people's lives more
recently we've narrowed these skills
down to what we call the ruler skills
the first is recognizing emotions so for
example looking at all of your facial
expressions and I'm thinking wow this is
not going so well
I am looking at your facial expression
thinking okay you interested are you
bored are you tired are you questioning
my what I'm saying
that's a natural thing for me as someone
who studies this all of you now will
just walk around everything I imagine
you're leaving here going to the
inauguration like this become paranoid
about everybody's facial expressions
understanding emotions where are they
coming from why do I feel angry what is
the theme for example around anger
versus sadness versus pride labeling
what are the words expressing how do i
express myself in appropriate ways in
different context and then finally
regulating emotions so let's break these
down a little bit when we talk about
recognizing emotions we're thinking
about it in terms of identifying emotion
in oneself to my own physiology my own
thoughts and others by looking at data
facial expressions body language posture
gesture vocal intonation how many of you
can tell how someone is feeling by a
conversation on the telephone you get
that vibe don't you let's try it right
now let's imagine that you want to show
the world on the telephone or in person
the feeling of compassion but you're not
going to say anything you're not gonna
use words you're just going to use a
sound are you ready on the count of one
the group everyone in here is going to
make the sound for compassion three two
one go
so there is something unique about
compassion right all right now we're
going to do all like you're in awe I
have to be careful cuz I'm from New
Jersey
oh you're going to the sound of awe
you're in awe of someone or something
ready three two one go
compassion it's not a little bit like
despair yes let's go back to awe
all right we're going to I have there is
some we have some work to do
understanding of emotion where do our
feelings come from how do they influence
our thinking our judgments our
decision-making our behavior like study
I showed you earlier how when you're in
that yellow mode do you just sort of
like say that's a great essay versus
when you're in that blue mood you say ah
you missed that little you know
semicolon or now that's not the best
word to describe that feeling state
right there so we know that our emotions
are constantly affecting our thinking
and judgment as a matter of fact you can
see from our mood meter now we can move
away from language and start thinking
about how the brain works and what are
the activities that we might want to
engage in in a classroom in each of
these quadrants because there is a bias
in our culture where everybody wants to
be happy all the time how many of you
believe it's realistic to be happy all
the time
that's good nobody raised anyone who's
her hand it's not realistic there's
death there's breakups there's all these
things in life yellow is great for
creative writing and brainstorming for
example I want to get people in a group
and have generate ideas for a topic
let's go put on loud music everyone gets
together generating ideas not the best
place for deciding on what you're going
to move forward with though is it think
about it you're feeling really pleasant
everything's fantastic someone asks you
a question go for it without really
thinking about it the green is wonderful
building for building consensus for
getting people's opinions together nice
calm energy so what do you think hmm
blue
some people say blue why would I want
ever be blue well has anyone here ever
wanted someone to express empathy to
them please raise your hand everybody is
a good thing
empathy tends to be a blue feeling
you're expressing your concern you're
expressing your feelings you're walking
in their shoes so we want children to be
to generate a feeling of empathy a lot
of people say red anger why would I want
anger we'll think about it
there's injustice in this world as a
matter of fact my anger for the way our
state not just this state but our nation
is dealing with bullying and it
infuriates me it infuriates me that
people think that you can solve problems
by creating zero-tolerance policies or
by telling people you have to give
bystanders you know the courage to stand
up to the bully I was one of those kids
who was bullied in school and guess what
you know I may look pretty confident now
but at 13 I was pretty introverted and
and and not in quite sensitive so the
idea that someone is going to tell me to
stand up to somebody who is bigger than
I am and tougher than I am and say leave
me alone it's pretty scary doesn't
really take into consideration a lot of
knowledge about child development or
individual differences in personality so
that anger that I feel about the way our
world manages constructs and ideas
motivates me it motivates me to work
harder to go down to Washington DC and
make speeches to lobbyists so you can
see here that from our perspective from
an emotionally intelligent perspective
all emotions are valid and important
it's what you do with them think about
it that read is useful but if you're
dysregulated and nasty not useful if you
convert it to passion now you have a
difference
labeling emotion building that
vocabulary to describe ourselves clearly
so I do this a lot I'm going to do it
I'm going to ask all of you right now
you have ten seconds to work with
someone at your where you are and I'd
like to know from you what the
difference is between jealousy and envy
10 seconds go
are you
okay time is up who feels confident who
feels like absolutely confident that
they can share yes sir okay okay so
jealousy is more negative than envy
you're saying any other thoughts this is
Yale by the way you're supposed to be
thinking yes sir ah interesting
so are you a couple now okay well that's
good come here come here come here by
the end of the weekend Internet what's
your name
Dana would you mind coming up come on no
no I need I need you
it takes two seconds I promise so you're
not going on the stage so everyone date
and I just you know we've we're going on
a date and we're walking down the street
and all of a sudden what's your name
again sir
Andres she sees undressed just take a
look at Andres very handsome if I see ya
but gala I want you to give him a look
like you've never given another man
see it's going to happen now I notice
Dana right yes looking at Andres that
way how do I feel jealous so now it's
obvious
so jealousy is about relationships
jealousy has to do with really I'm
jealous that you have a nicer tie than
me I'm envious but jealousy is about
dynamics it's about relationships thank
you tonight now my question is you know
something was all well this is like
intellectual jargon babble you know who
cares about the difference I mean we
just use these terms why would I want a
child or a teacher to understand the
difference between jealousy and envy yes
yes yeah jealousy can cause more
violence more aggression so the
strategies that I might use or teach a
child who is feeling jealous in a
classroom be very different than the
strategy that might teach a child who's
feeling envious expressing emotion for
curiosity does anyone here know anyone
who is socially inappropriate anyone
yeah that's where this skill comes into
play it's not knowing like the how and
the when to express your emotions I
won't give you any personal stories in
this era because they're not appropriate
but my point here is that there is that
level of appropriateness that has to do
with context and culture I'll never
forget when my other career is I'm a
martial artist I know I don't look like
one but I have a fifth degree black belt
in a martial art called Hapkido and when
I've gone to Korea when I went there the
first time I remember very vividly my
Americans you said don't look anybody in
the eyes it's rude and you know
inappropriate so I remember meeting my
teasing hello you know hello
and of course he thought I was like some
weirdo from America you know it's not
that extreme right there's subtle things
here right well when I teach in my
martial art studio everybody you know
that was you know I don't think any of
you going to bow to me at the end of
this presentation although it's not a
bad idea
the so there are cultural rules that we
had to be sensitive to there are rules
between New York and Connecticut I mean
I remember when I was a student in New
York City I would work in coffee shops
and a Lower East Side my friends would
come and say mark I'm depressed and
bloated and tired and I'm irritable you
know now I live in New Haven Connecticut
and it sort of like hello it's a little
different here emotionally I would say
have a gun a hug in ten years I'm
exaggerating a little bit but there are
differences there are differences in the
way people communicate about emotions
regulating emotions how many of you
believe that your lives would be
somewhat healthier happier even better
if you had more strategies to regulate
your own emotions raise your hand most
people agree with that it's interesting
another question how many of you believe
you'd be healthier and happier if
everyone who you live with had more
strategies to regulate their emotions
yeah
yeah this is when you know couples
therapy begins after this part what we
want to make sure we do is give people
teach people effective strategies for
managing their emotions and there are a
lot of them most of us know the negative
ones like negative self-talk rumination
worry abusing substances what about
positive self-talk what about positive
reappraisal what about visualizations
what about other more active strategies
like doing some yoga or exercise or
taking a walk and what we know is that
emotion regulation is more complex than
we originally thought it was it's not
just about down regulating the negative
emotions like anger management stress
management how many of you have ever
taken a course in optimism induction
think about it it'd be nice to teach a
little bit of strategies to be more
optimistic wouldn't it or happiness
maintenance the way we think about
emotion regulation is in terms of
helping people prevent unwanted emotions
reducing unwanted emotions initiating
emotions that may be necessary to
achieve a goal a good leader for example
has to be skilled at inspiring his team
or her team you got to be a generative
feeling in a row so that people can be
thinking in the way that you want them
to think like getting in that yellow for
that brainstorming session or in that
blue for that reflection maintenance to
me is interesting how do you maintain
emotions I was joke that I like to do
work in coffee shops it's just the way I
like to do my work and often times I do
my writing and different coffee shops
around town and my brother will call me
and I'll say things like you know how
you doing say I'm doing fine well I hear
all that noise in the background where
are you I'm in a coffee shop
oh so you're working in a coffee shop
yeah so the university pays you to sit
in coffee shops sort of and like that's
okay and all of a sudden like you're in
that flow state you're feeling really
positive you're working
he starts maybe I should be in my office
you know
by doing something wrong maybe I should
be out of here so you have these
pleasant emotions that people try to
pull away has anyone ever had a dream
stealer in their life someone who like
you know wow it's great that you get to
work in coffee shops you should come
work where I am and my question is how
do we bring people back up how do we
keep them there so when I get off the
telephone I'm feeling irritated and
annoyed at my brother that I can go back
to that place where I was feeling flow
and focused we spent a lot of time
thinking about how do you measure this
thing called emotional intelligence and
you can do a number doing a number of
ways first is you can ask the person
directly we're going to try that right
now as a matter of every do it a little
differently I want you to look at the
person or the people that you came with
just take a look at them for a minute
anyway look at somebody else look it's a
bit of stranger some of you might know
and I want you to just ask yourself this
question
how much more emotionally intelligent
are you than that person raise your hand
if you think you're more emotionally
intelligent the person you're with
now even nobody's going to do that now
here's the interesting thing about that
when I've done research on this like
paper and pencil like secret with my
even yellow undergraduate students 80%
say they're more intelligent and
emotionally intelligent than their
neighbor than their partner for those of
you who are familiar with like
probability and statistics you know 80%
can be smarter than the other 80%
so asking the person directly is
probably not the way to go that
self-report is complicated right well if
you ask me like how emotionally
intelligent a USA well compared to my
father I am an emotional genius compared
to the Dalai Lama you know I need some
work so there's no reference point it's
very complex our knowledge first of all
where we learned to be emotionally
intelligent you can ask other people how
many of you would rely on your
children's rating of your emotional
intelligence we won't go there today but
we tend to find that informant reports
or sometimes people call it 360 reports
are really not about your skills but
about your reputation whether or not
they like you or not not necessarily how
skilled you are at something and then
finally you can ask the person to solve
emotion latent problems which is the way
our Center manages the study of
emotional intelligence so Peter and Jack
Peter salivate and Jack Meir and David
Caruso developed the test years ago
called the Mesquite which was an ability
based assessment tool it was asking
people to solve problems look at facial
expressions decode them give you
complicated vignettes and say what would
be the best way to manage that situation
what we're doing now in our Center is
working with gaming companies to build
virtual tests or using avatars so we're
going to bring people into a world and
having requiring you to sort of look the
world and make judgments about
expressions and deal with emotions which
we're very excited about
but unfortunately self-knowledge is
quite limited and it's interesting
because our world has tried to move
towards very sort of simple ways of
doing this and what our research shows
is that measuring emotional intelligence
by asking people like how good you are
regulating your emotions and things of
that sort just doesn't have any validity
everybody wants to know what does this
predict about people's lives
we've done a lot of studies on students
young adolescents what we know is that
children with higher emotional
intelligence tend to experience less
anxiety they tend to have less
depression they tend to be less likely
in middle school in high school to abuse
alcohol drugs and cigarettes they tend
to be less aggressive and less likely to
engage in bullying behavior they also
are perceived by their teachers and
their peers as being better leaders
they're more attentive and less
hyperactive and what's important in our
nation right now is academic performance
and what we show is that children with
higher emotional intelligence just do
better academically they have those
skills to manage those challenging
moments what's interesting to me about
this work is how powerful that skill of
emotion regulation is in determining the
quality of your academic performance and
my own life is an example I was
unfortunately and not well when I was in
my early 20s my mother passed away right
before I came and went to graduate
school and I remember being in that room
taking the GREs to go to graduate school
and it was just a few months after my
mom had passed and just literally like
he's quit who's the protagonist who's
the antagonist I mean I was so just in
the grieving space that I couldn't focus
I couldn't take the test well and I
realized it had now as an adult a bigger
adult that it had nothing to do with my
ability to problem-solve it just that my
emotional life was interfering at that
moment in my life with my cognitive
ability and what I hope happens is that
people take that more seriously that
people understand the nuances that some
people have anxiety around testing some
people are in a place in their life
where they're not capable of doing
complex problem-solving because of
outside influences like that child who
is being bullied in school we've worked
on emotional intelligence among
educators themselves and look what we
know they're more positive about T
they received more support from their
principals go figure
they even report greater job
satisfaction have less burnout we've
moved beyond the study of emotional
intelligence in children and adults and
gone into studying the dynamics of
classrooms so what we do is we work with
other researchers to develop systems of
coding the quality of interactions
between teachers and students and then
what we do is we use those data to
predict performance so for example a
teacher who uses more positive nonverbal
behavior a teacher who regards a
student's perspective and brings them
into the learning environment who uses
less cynicism and sarcasm and when we
code that using videotaped analysis and
then we use it to predict things we find
the following students in those
classrooms are just more engaged
learners they have better quality
relationships with their teachers
they're more pro-social and they perform
better academically so how many of you
are starting to have more buy-in for the
power of emotional intelligence anyone
if you don't raise your hand you have to
leave we've also had the opportunity to
study managers and leaders of
organizations because people want to
know what is that to do with the real
world you know when someone's in their
20s 30s 40s 50s and Beyond in the
workplace and as you can see here adults
managers of organizations are just
better off when they have these skills
as a matter of fact we did a study with
a fortune 100 company recently where we
had the hundred managers of this of this
company take our tests of emotional
intelligence and we had the CEO the CFO
and the CEO of that organization do a
rating of the 100 managers and that last
question was one I just experimented
with which was this if you had to leave
this company tomorrow what would you do
anything to take that person with you
and how to rate every one of those
hundred managers on that particular
question that was the strongest
cartlett of emotional intelligence
people just want to be around people
that have these skills and it's
interesting for me because
and I'm here I am at Yale University
working with some of the brightest
students in the world and I teach it I
used this is my first day teaching was
in this classroom actually and I had
about 380 students in my class and I
looked at all of them and I said Wow
in four years from now on paper you're
all going to look exactly the same
you have great SAT scores you have
perfect GPAs you've studied abroad in
the country that I've never heard of you
play an instrument that only three
people know how to play but you're going
to go apply for this job and you know
when you I get about 30 40 50
applications a year to work in our
Center now I don't look at their grades
I mean who cares at this point I know
they're smart enough to do the work so
what are the things that I'm looking for
it's can they work in it as a team did
they make you feel comfortable
I actually because I like coffee shops I
have what I call the coffee shop
criteria which is in the first 30
seconds if I say to myself I would love
to go to have a cup of coffee with this
person just shoot the breeze that's my
decision making and because I get that
feeling that they're going to be
interesting they're going to be creative
they're going to have these they're
going to how to ask you questions all
the things that we tend not to really
teach people always ask how does this
thing called emotional intelligence
develop and of course you have nature
and nurture simple psych 101 how many of
you just for curiosity are biologically
predisposed like me to be more anxious
and worried about things anyone okay the
front row so you must really want like
we came to learn we want those
strategies so that's the nature piece
right we all have a temperament a
personality and some of us are more just
a prone to being attuned and aware of
emotion we also all grew up in a family
some of us grew up you know what raised
by wolves some of us were raised by
people who really knew a lot about
emotion I have a question for all of you
how many of you believe as you think
about your own childhood for a minute
you can think you're gonna have to do
that and today like don't do that to me
believe that you grew up in an are in a
family environment where emotional
intelligence was nurtured please raise
your hand so a few of you that's my goal
is for that number to be much larger in
the next decade every parent should be
learning these skills every parent needs
to know how to talk to their students
about emotions I did a training it was
at a boarding school yesterday in
upstate New Hampshire and I had about
150-200 parents and one parent says so
you mean it's okay for my son to be sad
and I'm like yeah good what do you mean
like what do you mean by that she's like
well like you know I just wanted to be
happy all the time I said that's great
but the reality is that he's going to
have some disappointment it's in his
life and you know sometimes being there
for a little while to think about the
some of our most creative people are the
artists of our generation that's sadness
is what inspired them to develop their
products as a matter of fact we now have
a study that shows that people who are
more creative just biologically who are
more open to experience only are rated
in terms of their products as being
creative when they're high in emotional
intelligence and think about it why is
that
because when you're creative and you're
trying things that you're going to fail
a lot you're going to have
disappointments a lot and unless you
have those strategies to manage that
disappointment that creative potential
just will not be unleashed our goal is
to make sure as I say everybody with a
face gets trained in emotional
intelligence because what we know is
that when you have that training from
preschool to high school and Beyond you
have those important outcomes in life so
I think we're here I ask you this
question already you know most of us
didn't get this training and most of us
don't have concrete tools so I want to
share with you for my last few minutes
is what do we do in schools and other
organizations about this thing
emotional intelligence and we've
developed our approach that we call
ruler people in New Hampshire tend to
call it ruler makes me crazy but it's
okay and the idea behind ruler is that
educating the mind without educating the
heart is no education at all not an
original quote by the way millennia ago
this was said my question is why is it
taking till 2014 for our nation's
education system to take this seriously
still pushing a lot of work to do we
have what we call the anchors of
emotional intelligence how many of you
remember when you were to school there
were rules classroom rules school rules
right no running keep your hands to
yourself only talk when you know this
years ago is probably an only talk when
spoken to I mean all these crazy rules
what we find is that how many of you
like to break rules I hate rules I love
finding a way to break those rules we
decided to move away from rules and say
let's think about the environment that
we want to create knowing that that
positive climate in a classroom matters
so much how can we be in not what's the
word I'm thinking of how can we be
intentional about creating it so we
asked kids and students how do you want
to feel in school you'd be blown away
but what they say they say I want to
feel respected I want to feel supported
I want to feel valued I want to feel
empowered I want to feel inspired and
then we say well what do you have to do
on a daily basis in order to have those
feelings what are the behaviors that you
can engage in to make sure that everyone
in your learning environment feels that
way and knowing that there's going to be
conflict and aggression what can we do
to prevent it and manage it and that's
done from the leadership down to the
student level we all learned that mood
meter already building that self
awareness the third tool is called the
meta moment as you can see it has six
steps this is our tool for
self-regulation we make very strong
claims in our research that if you take
the six steps of the meta moment
seriously you can avoid the 12 steps
later
apologies for those of you who I just
offended step one if something happens
how many of you have triggers like you
know my triggers right like if you think
about your home life it's like didn't we
agree that you were going to do that
remember that or at work people who
trigger you littlest things right the
little things some big things too we
want to teach people to be aware of
their triggers we know that all emotions
affect the way we think our physiology
and our behavior so we're doing is
giving children and adults that
knowledge of how our emotions are
affecting the shift in our thinking how
many of you been angry in the last month
about something anyone how many of you
knows when you've been angry like you're
angry about everything do you know I
remember that like I'm not just angry
remember three years ago when we're on a
vacation
do you remember that time do you
remember that remember last week you
promised you were going to pick that up
for me do you remember that and do you
remember when our child was born
I mean you it's like you just go back
and you just start digging for that you
know is anger is one of those emotions
you just search for all the reasons we
want to stop that from happening so you
go to step three and you take that
breath you activate your parasympathetic
nervous system and you take that breath
and you bring that hijacked experience
down a little bit so that your
prefrontal cortex can help you to
problem-solve and make sense out of it
and do something because when you're
hijacked how many of you experience that
hijack honestly and there's no coming
back I'm going for the jugular
if we have seen it since this is evoking
a lot of emotions step forward seeing
your best self for us it's important to
have motivation to be regulated
you know I joke a lot I say sometimes I
think that breath try to calm down and I
say to myself wow how am I going to just
rip your head off so it's not enough to
just breathe you have to know how to
shift your mindset and that's where our
best self peace comes in where we teach
children what is your best self look
like what does it look like for you you
know it just bring this this lecture is
bringing back memories because I got the
idea for this best self peace working
with my colleague Robin and also by
teaching your course where one of my
students wrote an article about my
course on emotional intelligence and the
article title was the feelings master
and I started selves al embarrassed by
of course you like the feelings master
but then I started thinking like you
know finally as a feelings master walk
you know I have the feelings master has
good posture I tend to be a sh leper you
know no feeling and then the feeling
master has students you know I get some
of those winners you know like professor
bracket I've got a question but I'm not
sure you're gonna know the answer
love those students you know and you
know that feelings non master is like oh
you're kidding me right
like you're kidding me you're kidding me
did you know about the research that I
do on emotions and judgments and grading
remember that
so I can't go there I gotta be the
feelings master the feelings mattress
says this is a teachable moment let's
talk about that do you think that's the
best way to approach your professor to
engage him in the process of
higher-order thinking and then when we
have that best self activated we can
strategize effectively we can choose and
use adaptive versus maladaptive
strategies and then have more success in
our social interactions knowing that
sometimes problem-solving doesn't work
that you try it in the moment but you
fail even I you know I've been working
on the stuff for years even at home
sometimes I think mark your the feelings
master and then that that that piece
from here says and he doesn't care right
now go for it and then of course you
know I'm sleeping alone on the couch
that night but you never regret taking
him at a moment I can promise you that
you never regret being your best self
you always regret being dysregulated
problem solving we have to teach our
children from our perspective to
empathize to build perspective taking
skills to not just look at it from the
me-me-me-me
but from the we and the us and the our
so when we have a conflict in schools
what we do is it's not just about you
uh-uh how did you think the other person
felt what were they feeling just before
that whole argument got started and gets
them to really think about the dynamic
in their relationship and that's our
blueprint and very importantly we train
everybody with a face I don't care who
you are in a school whether you work in
the front office or whether you work in
the back office or whether you're the
superintendent or the preschooler
everybody's learning this stuff and we
have a theory for why that makes a
difference we're not just sitting coffee
shops all the time by the way we
actually do do science and what we know
is that when you train leaders teachers
and staff when you train this classroom
and give that curriculum in that
classroom and when you bring in families
and teach parents the same skills and
the same tools that their children are
learning great things happen
you get to enhance the skills of all
people in that environment and that also
helps this shift simultaneously the
culture so there's a common language so
a superintendent can walk into the
preschool and say hey how you feelin
today the little boy I'm in the yellow
and me too what's your strategy I'm
going to stay there and then we show in
our research that when you enhance
people's emotional intelligence and
shift the culture and climate you get
those important outcomes that we all
care about for our children and the
adults involved in our education better
engagement achievement better
relationships list bullying and
aggression greater health and well-being
I just stood at the end we've done a
number of research studies to show that
this stuff really matters experiments in
schools to show that when schools can
adopt this approach these are the kinds
of outcomes you can expect less anxiety
and depression children become better
problem solvers have greater social and
leadership skills experience fewer
attention and learning problems and they
also perform better academically that
climate that I said matters so much
we've shown that we can shift that as
well
we shift between 10 and 50 percent in
just one year all three of these the
emotional climate children feel more
engaged they want to be there the
instructional climate teachers become
better instructors in general better
modeling of language but a classroom
management I'm going to wrap up today by
showing a short video I have had the
privilege to travel around the world to
do this work and right now our approach
called ruler is in about 700 schools
throughout the world and many years ago
I was in England where I began a lot of
my international work and I had the
opportunity to really do some
interesting studies in England as well
as create a lab in a school and there
was a little boy in this school who I
never met until after he had been
trained
in emotional intelligence his name is
Gareth and Gareth was a little boy who
was horrific Lee bullied in his
elementary school and then went to this
middle school that was very different
they had embraced emotional intelligence
and this is a poem that he wrote in his
class on emotional intelligence about
his experiences of bullying and the way
he thought about it now is a little bit
different than he thought about it
previously I know he told this feel
silly I know I realize this you look
like a I know this has been pointed out
to me you have two big eyes I know I
have looked in the mirror you can't be a
pilot enough smart enough it is possible
I have considered yes remember you
thought you invented a stranger but it's
true
you point out how many failures and
helped me to improve did you harm at how
many weaknesses
you also highlight our strengths my own
fitness needs to my client personality
my silliness brings laughs a world I
resemblance to move yet it only
highlights my televisions my bigger eyes
betray my feelings and widen my view I
may not make it as planned if I couldn't
Lee you see every insult you invent
gives me a view into your mind know how
many problems I feel sorry for me why oh
why do I feel sorry for you because you
might not make
three the wall of insults you build
limits your mind and feelings so soon if
you don't stop you're turning clearly
not the biggest problem for learners
think about
so you know as we think about this boy's
life
in school how was he able to get he was
a seedy failing student in fifth and
sixth grade how could he have been
successful when that's the way he felt
about his life when that's the way he
felt he thought other people felt about
him
Gareth went into the school where he was
feeling much safer more confident he was
developing skills and he wrote this poem
and originally he they were doing public
speaking and he said I just I'm not
ready and I'm scared to share it because
I don't know what's going to happen if I
share it and the teacher of course
having been trained said well you know
what Gareth that's okay you don't have
to share it right now
but is it okay if I share with other
teachers he said that would be fine so
here is now in this new elementaries
from middle school the poem has been
brought around and teachers come out
Garren's you're so articulate Garrett
that poem how meaningful how wonderful
that poem was his self-esteem is
building he says to his teacher a few
weeks later I'm ready to read it to the
class
he reason to the class lo and behold to
get the standing ovation from his peers
they say we wouldn't treat anybody like
that here that's not the way we do
business in this school and what's
interesting about Gareth this is about
three or four years ago now I've gone
back to this school
he's in high school now and I remember
sitting just about two years ago in the
cafeteria work you know having meetings
and he came with you sir do you remember
me I said of course I remember you I've
been exploiting you throughout in
America
and so of course I remember you
and he goes you know I want to be a poet
I said that's fantastic and I said he
because and I have a girlfriend now I
said great and he said you want to read
some more of my pumps and absolutely and
he's like brings me this pile of things
and he walks away and he says you know
sir
look for me on the bookshelves you know
I can take credit for Gareth because I
wasn't his teacher and I get emotional
just thinking about it because when I
think about what it was like for him
like it was for me in elementary school
not having that ability to connect not
having that ability to feel safe and
valued how could you survive in that
environment now he's in a place where he
feels safe where he feels valued where
he can succeed from the reading of his
poem we know that he's academically
gifted but you can't show your academic
or cognitive ability if you're feeling
oppressed or you're feeling unvalued or
not value so I will end today by reading
a poem by roommate that really gets at
the value and importance of all emotions
this being human is a guest house every
morning a new arrival a joy a depression
a meanness some momentary awareness
comes as an unexpected visitor welcome
and entertain them all even if they're a
crowd of sorrows who violently sweep
your house empty of its furniture still
treat each guest honorably
he may be clearing you out for some new
delight the dark thought the shame the
malice meet them at the door laughing
and invite them in be grateful for
whoever comes because each has been sent
as a guide from beyond so I want to
thank you for your time and attention
and I hope you have a wonderful
wonderful weekend here at Yale it was a
indeed a privilege and a pleasure to
present to all of you thank you